this shed is disinfected every few hours
at least a dozen cows are quarantined
here sick from a viral skin disease this
rehab center in the state of rajasthan
is home to nearly 1700 animals many are
infected
authorities say they first spotted
symptoms two months ago
we get a lot of cows from the city some
have been in accidents even those you
see eating garbage on the streets are
brought here we check for symptoms when
they arrive even those without symptoms
are kept away from our herds for weeks
lumpy skin disease is spread mostly by
flies and mosquitoes lumps like these
start appearing on the skin animals
become weak and get fever it's spreading
fast
thousands of animals have died across
india most of them are cows rajasthan
state is the worst affected the disease
emerged in zambia a century ago in
recent years parts of asia have reported
cases here in india it regularly
infected sheep and goats this is the
first time that thousands of cattle have
caught the disease
laliby's family owns 15 cows like
millions of others their livelihood
depends on cattle she says she hasn't
let them out in weeks
if they fall sick it will impact the
milk we can also fall sick and our
incomes will also fall on top of that
the treatment will cost us a lot of
money
officials say they're testing animals
regularly the goat box vaccine is being
given across india
but some districts are reporting a
shortage of medicines and doctors milk
production has also reduced in some
areas depend a lot on cattle they use
them in fields and for milk low milk
production affects the economy and their
incomes we want the government to
promise them free medicines
vets are checking on the cattle and the
treatment is free even here the
government is funding the treatment
[Music]
rajasthan's government is asking for
donations to help fund the treatment
officials say they plan to vaccinate as
many animals to prevent future outbreaks
pavni mittal al jazeera jaipur in
western india